y aura-t-il un débat ou pas le 15
octobre hamiani non répond d'un autre
chien en entrevue sur fox news
[Applaudissements]
je ne vais pas perdre mon temps sur un
débat virtuel dit il c'est ridicule
d'être devant un ordinateur ils vont
interrompre tout le temps joe biden ne
sait plus sur quel pied danser avec dans
notre chambre où l'on ait peu de temps
je ne sais pas quoi dire dit il le
président change d'avis toutes les
secondes
s'ils organisent un rassemblement
politique ce jour là je ne sais pas ce
qu'on va faire dans notre chambre
propose de repousser ce débat au 29
octobre
l'équipe hayden refuse car elle estime
que c'est trop près du 3 novembre
en attendant les américains se
contenteront du débat vise
présidentielle qui a été écoutée par
plus de 50 millions de téléspectateurs 9
thèmes ont été abordés dont la gestion
de la pandémie
la cour suprême et à la question en
va-t-il y avoir une passation de pouvoir
pacifique
mike pence ne garantit rien will try to
work shop ignore quand vous parlez
d'accepter les résultats dit-il votre
parti a passé trois ans à essayer de
nous renverser
nous allons nous battre contre ce vote
par correspondance qui va créer de la
fraude ajoutent ils la tension monte
entre les deux camps aujourd'hui le fbi
a arrêté six personnes d'une milice qui
projetait de kidnapper la gouverneure
démocrate du michigan
il aurait tenté d'acheter des explosifs
[Applaudissements]
c'était en avril dernier plusieurs
manifestants armés avaient pris d'assaut
le capitole du michigan il reprochait la
gouverneur d'avoir des règles trop
sévère de confinement des gens très bien
qui sont en colère avait twitté
d'amundsen à 26 jours des élections le
ton monte entre les deux candidats
l'équipe byden parle d'un président
erratique
quant à donne aux femmes qui l'accusent
joe biden de se cacher dans son sous-sol
un avant goût du prochain débat
présidentiel
ici à 0 de ligue 1 qui serait du canada
à washington